[Music]
[Applause]
bad
welcome back to the break room from new
rock stars and we are back in the break
room
physically here break room oh we've got
i forgot to put my art back that goes
over there oh okay
might just stolen from my office i want
everyone to know it was stolen from my
office if i stand up haven't been found
if i stand up straight can you see me
oh not in this case
who are you talking to the audience
um
[Applause]
well it's the eternal john cena question
can you see me um
we've got so much to talk about today
star wars celebration has been unfolding
all day today our compatriots and
co-workers tommy bechtel and eric voss
are down there they're reporting on on
the unfoldings the releases the news the
drops that are coming out of star wars
celebrations
[Laughter]
sheets out of your linen closet you know
that's what we're doing today with news
about andor we got a big ol andor
trailer our first good peek at that
series we got news about ahsoka kenobi
obviously and a lot more
um a little a willow news here or there
uh uh some indiana jones 5 news no
yes
i don't know i just uh i read that
kathleen kennedy interview where she uh
really sat on the guy who played solo in
the standalone movie and she talked
about how she's like it's just like
harrison ford and indiana jones you just
can't ever do it without harrison ford
yeah and i was like oh so they're going
to drag this man into his grave i know
just do it let him rest he's not trying
to do the tom cruise thing yeah yeah
yeah he wants to just go and like crash
airplanes on an island somewhere
but we want to hear from you throw your
and or thoughts questions into the chat
any any of this big news that's coming
out of star wars celebration all the
lucasfilm news please throw that in the
chat we're gonna get to those we're
gonna do a big ol q a at the end also
we'll be trying to uh answer those as
they come about during the show we also
appreciate anybody throwing a couple
doubloons our way in the super chat
as a little thank you every time we hit
a multiple of a hundred on the super
chat it will unlock
the break room swear jar now the break
room swear jar is more state of mind
than it does a physical jar
and it's just did somebody steal the jar
that's right yeah they took your art and
they took their culprit
but the swear jar again when it unlocks
it allows one of us here on the panel to
swear profusely otherwise profusely
profusely every time
this is ridiculous i know it's it's
complicated like all good things yeah
what you wanted us to do
so when we hit a multiple of 100 a poll
will show up in the chat to uh for who
you would like to use profanity and then
that person will be allowed to be
profane weird thing to vote on you're
absolutely correct we keep it we keep it
wild we keep it weird here on the break
room but first let's get into some of
these headlines
yeah there's gonna be a sound effect
with that i don't i don't know yeah
something i don't know that's a terrible
sound effect um
that'd be a better one
um first in in we have a a little bit of
non-star wars related news on lucasfilm
news we'll get to that first here uh
michael waldron
the genius behind loki and multiverse of
madness and lots of other great content
confirmed that there was talk about
making villain
the uh the villain in multiverse of
madness be nightmare
i almost said making villain the
nightmare right it was nightmare the
villain um which you know long
speculation there was even rumors that
that was the reason scott derrickson
left the project because he wanted
nightmare but the studio wouldn't let
him use it
so this kind of we got confirmation that
that was legitimate there was at some
point talk of nightmare being the main
villain michael waldron said at one
point that he actually completed a draft
i i think at least a full draft of the
script where wanda was not debilitating
they have to do multiple it seems like a
lot of mcu projects have to make
multiple scripts just in case i know
that moon knight did moon knight was
like there's a bunch of different
versions of what it could be and then
they have now are these writers getting
paid i don't know i
don't know i don't know and that's the
real wga rules uh being bent here but
also wga rules
hell yeah hell yeah writer's guild um
we support organized labor here um uh
but um organized well it is interesting
and it is like when you're making a
billion-dollar property right why not
throw a couple different drafts out
there there's probably all kinds of
moving parts you know i think that's the
only way to do it is because it's also
like
what happens if something major happened
to thor love and thunder and they had to
change something up it's like okay well
we need to go back to this script
that does happen a lot i have a friend
who works at marvel and he says that he
they will be working well into a story
and then find out hey your villain never
mind you can't use them somebody else
already turns out they have them uh new
villain please
there's also a lot of chaos there in
general in this system
they're writing all these scripts
michael waldron is writing the script
for the kevin feige produced star wars
movie that kathleen kennedy says does
not exist
and he and michael waldron just said
almost done
there's a lot going on well somebody's
lying uh and we're all trying that's the
best we can do uh marvel revealed the
updated she-hulk cgi this kind of came
out the trailer that is currently on
disney plus i believe has a different
version of the cgi than the trailer that
came out via youtube there have been
some updates some people are speculating
they did another pass
oh we got that graphic up there
yeah okay so the question for me is is
it actually did they go back and change
anything it looks like ugly
oh it does feel like it's just higher
res that image just feels like it's a
high-res image and this might also not
be the version we ultimately see in the
series yeah there might be more changes
before the show is related
that's right that's right
i will say that like the more i stare at
her it's i don't know why and i'm being
super honest here i'm not making a joke
the more attractive i'm finding the
character i think i'm starting to
retroactively uh remind myself of the
she-hulk comics where they really like
sexualized that character i don't know
if you guys have seen like the artwork
it was like this she her towel was too
small or something but like little boy
phillip is getting all confused yes he's
getting all confused i always thought
she was hot yes and and you know like
there's something to be said the uncanny
valley can be uh a sexy valley yeah
uncanny valley is a little too uncanny
or the uncanny it's too sexy well i was
gonna say the uncanny valley could be a
metaphor for a certain body part okay
um uh but
let's pivot before we get into trouble
vagina
okay
hey we're trying to get to star wars
famous because they ain't us that's all
i'm going to say
my favorite comment from yesterday
yeah but we've got so much great news to
talk about coming out of the star wars
celebration down in anaheim where our
buddies tommy and eric are down there uh
first let's let's start
smallest to biggest i don't know
farthest away to nearest maybe
indiana jones five we got a release date
june 30th 2023 23. can we get the math
on how old harrison ford is going to be
30th 2023 please
i mean a legit 80 uh maybe in the chat
folks
how old he's because he was surprisingly
old when a new hope came out right like
he'd already had like a lot a full
80 on the news
[Music]
a year older well no he's the exact same
age as judge judy
wow so judge judy could be indiana jones
to be fair judge judy's still somehow
making her tv show well she has to sit
and bang a gown that's right and be
sassy that's what harrison ford wants to
do
i mean
it is wild i mean he's again
no ageism here but he's he's been old
for a while the fact that he's been able
to make any kind of action movies like
uh force awakens in the last indiana is
he going to be like the professor in
jurassic park like he is just going to
be like you guys know what i'm talking
about the old man in jurassic park no
the only one hammond
yeah is he just going to be like this is
what this is what i do for a job and
have all the other people do all the
running and moving yeah he has like a
corporate indiana jones inc yeah like we
collect the relics and get them into the
museum where they belong maybe he's the
charlie of charlie's angels kind of a
vibe right where he's got a team of
young whippersnappers to do his bidding
kind of a thing they tried that with
shia labeouf yes what was the last movie
india indiana jones was in that dog
movie and he moved a lot in that oh are
you just you're just referring to
harrison ford as indiana jones now
exactly indiana jones has had a separate
film career i'm just measuring the
amount of movement he can make in this
movie uh well based on how much judge
judy moves oh my god i would say that
he's fine judy works out a lot
she works out a lot if you have a lot of
problems with people too that's right uh
we're excited we only got a still image
of this and it's just kind of harrison
ford and silhouette uh john do we have
that asset um
but you know it's cool this movie is
closer than i kind of thought it was
that's almost exactly a year out that
means like they've been filming right
like uh
the process is underway these movies
take a really long time to make so
that's cool that's gonna be exciting for
next year i wonder i'm genuinely curious
how much it's gonna be that thing of um
what's the netflix movie with the
gangsters
oh pacino
oh no
the irishman whatever where it's like
these old old men but they cgi'd them to
look young or whatever but they moved
terribly yeah they made the movie four
hours long um i just hope it's mostly
footage from what lies beneath hell yeah
uh honestly michelle pfeiffer also
confusing
yes well she's like the reverse of like
i could never tell is she 40 or 90 i
don't know she looks great you know that
quantum time that's right it's a it's a
age
cure there um on to some major star wars
celebration news and announcements we
actually from our reporter in the field
tommy bechtold we have a video
we have a video of tommy coming stealing
eric boss is wi-fi in his hotel
don't tell anybody
just got done with the big panel we got
our first trailer for andor the place
went absolutely ballistic
i went absolutely ballistic eric had to
calm me down
he actually won't be associated with me
right now that's why he's not in the
video but uh
yeah we got to see
basically
a minute and 30 seconds of the show
where there's i mean looks like it's
shot a lot on location not so much um
green screen or blue screen
uh we've got some great appearances by
some of the actors gonna be in stone sky
guards playing the rebel captain
i'm a little out of breath i'm sorry
it's because i had a great time
the rest of the panel oh my god i gotta
tell you guys more about it
when i can because it was unbelievable
let's just say it ended
with john williams so you can imagine
what happened in the middle of it
uh
so break room
you're in good hands today i love you
all
uh may the force be with you
okay thank you tommy
uh are you back in the office yes also
tommy please catch your breath my man uh
i think it might be too much stimulation
down time for tommy uh he's in his happy
place right now uh yeah that we all
watch the trailer for andor yes we are
maybe at a similar excitement level
though we're not showing it quite as
much as tommy um it looks so cool i
would the thing he pointed out about
like yeah there's clearly a lot of cgi
maybe they're kind of using that cool
disney technology of the giant um led
green screen thing i think they're not
using that
super exciting about it because once now
you see again like oh right the world is
is real and you can kind of tell the
difference now yes it does make you feel
like uh i don't know about those
mandalorian 360 screens yeah
yeah well the great advantage of the
it's cheaper and easier to shoot on
those mandalorian 360s especially maybe
in kova times but maybe this is like oh
this is the cool postcovid yeah we can
go to iceland or namibia or hungary or
whatever yeah spending all that that
money on that little grogu puppet
you can get a real grow goat yeah yeah
exactly and go to where those live yeah
oh i would steal so many i don't care
how many times it would kill my family
by accident or something i feel like it
would just like crush my house by
accident just constantly yeah like with
pipes i mean in all your frog collection
oh no you eat all the eggs you just eat
all these and the frogs
put in the chat any questions you guys
have about andor we're going to do a
little bit more on andor but we're kind
of just knocking out our headlines right
now yes uh we'll we'll be coming back ah
lucasfilm announced a willow series for
disney plus they've kind of talked about
this before we got our first trailer our
first look at the willow series and this
is a sequel to the 1988
film willow also produced by i've never
seen it oh really
it's a good time is it yes it seems like
scary
i don't know
we're gonna have to watch it it's
definitely somebody who like one of my
biggest fears and phobias is like a
changeling or a shape-shifter there is
some change laying shapeshift he talks
about this
and last time i said i wanted to know
why
and instead tommy started stuttering a
lot and it distracted it
wow there maybe some of it comes from
this film which i watched as a very
young person um
and there is a certain scene where
somebody like rapidly transforms to all
kinds of different creatures maybe that
imprinted on me but i'm excited for this
series it features quasi friend of the
program tony revolori hey i have a
picture with tony revelry that i won't
show anyone because i look terrible okay
but tony looks great yeah he looks so
good in it
also for those people that are in the
chat yes the trailer for andor did come
out yeah a lot of people were like wait
it came out it came out yeah there's a
reaction we've already got a new
rockstar has a reaction with tommy and
uh eric standing in a parking lot
outside of the convention center
reacting to it in real time they
actually they are at the convention
center as much as it seems like they're
faking it and that they're not actually
there yes and i think that maybe tommy
or eric one of both of them have some
pictures on social media showing them
indoors okay um for all those truthers
out there that never think they're just
standing in the parking lot um but yeah
i'm i'm pretty excited i gotta say this
this trailer looked great you know it's
part of
the willow the willow trailer we got a
lot of trailers trailer too we got
it still features warwick davis um as
willow this is just set in you know
davis was in star wars he was he was
inside of a couple of different uh roles
um
yes and and he has worked a ton of
course if you don't know who i'm
referring to warwick davis the second
you see him in the trailer you'll be
like oh that guy um that guy it looks
like you know
that oh i get all the warwick's confused
uh dion um but it looks like a lot of
fun it looks like maybe you know it's
got some of that fantasy
a little bit of baby game of thrones
probably not nearly as heavy a lot more
baby game of thrones i would watch like
crazy where it's just babies but they're
targaryens
just battling for the crib no but like
i'm more a family-friendly i doubt
there'll be a lot of incest in willow uh
probably fewer beheadings uh than in
game of thrones it looks i gotta say the
trailer looks great uh you know part of
willow it was mid 80s um so you know
some of that cgi some of those early
special effects
you might watch that and be like oh
that's quaint but the special effects at
least on the trailer look great can you
give me a one sentence premise of what
is willow so it's it's a little lord of
the rings rip off e in that warwick
davis plays a little person who gets
recruited for like a mythical quest to
save this princess from an evil witch
along the way befriends a val kilmer
portrayed mad martign who's like this
outlaw sword swordsman kind of badass
they team up they're an odd couple they
go defeat the witch release the princess
this is like a very close to you film
yes
i think it's close to everyone because
people in the chat were like this is an
instance i know i think hey can we throw
up a poll what what percentage of people
think yeah both things have seen it and
demand that philip and jessica tonight
watch what life watch it you don't need
to demand it i'm definitely gonna watch
it i just need to know how many people
know it hate tonight is it a good day i
think you should cancel your date oh no
no no you just need some time alone with
willow oh god
but i think you know and certainly now
we're getting this series coming out uh
the end of this year november 30th 2022
watch willow ahead of it ahead of the
release um we got uh some news
this is brand new i think kind of
completely unexpected some casting news
jude law
is going to be starring in a star wars
series star wars skeleton crew um we
knew that there was a star wars series
built around some kind of young actors
like kind of a kids coming of age story
helmed by john watts and chris ford
the writer director of spider-man
homecoming and of course john watts the
director of all the tom holland
spider-man movies but they're they're
doing this series called star wars
skeleton crew we don't know a lot about
it other than jude lost stars as the
only adult actor we know so far one of
the kids yeah
that's really extreme irishman there
yeah doesn't jude law give off major
empire vibes you know like he almost
seems like a young it's got a british
accent kind of like cold features yeah
but we don't
we don't know what a role he's playing
but we know this takes place after kind
of the fall of the empire post return of
the jedi kids coming of age yes
cool
very very cool there's like all these
times are so rich and interesting that's
what i'm most excited about uh on andor
but we'll get back to that yes um dave
filoni quoted as saying it's all
connected when asked how of course it
better be
it better be the day felony quoted as
this one doesn't have anything to do
with anything this one's tossed out you
don't need to watch that yeah we got
some release dates for series we already
knew about mandalorian season three and
ahsoka both now slated for 2023. we kind
of suspected ahsoka was coming out next
year we had kind of hoped mandalorian
might sneak into the end of 2022 but now
we know december january yes and it's
just pushed a little bit i think
mandalorian season three is gonna be
february of next year with ahsoka coming
some time after that i think those two
are my number one like those are what
i'm looking forward to like i was like i
can't wait to when these two properties
drop first is it because groguru is
going to start puberty yes
because i really want a child and the
closest i can get is kroger
uh grogu and because anything rosario
dawson yeah yes gets my boat light my
candle the the van it was a vanity fair
entertainment weekly but the the cover
photos that they did with uh
her pedro pascal and aaron mcgregor i
will never pronounce his name correctly
i'm not going to try so
aaron aaron mcgregor yeah i went to high
school over there
he was a great guy it's he's fine either
way
i was like this is
these three people are gonna blow my
mind and they're the three people i need
to protect at all times maybe not
mcgregor but pedro pascal and rosario
dawson two people i will always that's
just like a bisexual dream right there
they
they're
no one's good enough for her for me if i
was like what celebrities good enough
for rosario does and i'm like none of
them she's perfect except for petrified
frisco pedro and oscar isaac those are
the shots fired it's senator cory booker
yes okay
get out speaking of mandalorian uh
attendees at
star wars celebration including eric
voss and tommy bechtold got a sneak peek
at some footage from mandalorian season
three
eric there that this footage has not
been released we haven't seen it but
eric kind of synopsized it in a tweet
that john we don't have the tweet we can
pull up right
yes but i'll just read the tweet which
is almost as good as seeing a tweet
um that he said the uh
the armorer shames mando for removing
his helmet mando explores the living
waters of mandalore bo katan on a
weathered throne grief karga in a sweet
fit oh carl weathers grief cargo
yeah that means that and that might be
on on mandalore which is like all
destroyed to hell it's like uh uh what
is the thing the ozymandias um quote
like behold my uh yeah or whatever just
like on this this throne of rubble and
and we have yet to have seen at least in
the live-action star wars universe we've
never been to mandalore heard about it
so many so many times seen so many
people there came from mandalore it's on
all the maps yeah uh but we have not
been there so that's exciting it seems
like not only are we going there we
might spend some time there we might
like there might be a decent amount of
this season spent on mandalore and
that's gonna be really cool hey as long
as it's not another sand planet
let's hope for moisture on mandalore
hashtag moisture on mandalore um
that's your platform you're gonna run
away that's right i hate that more than
anything along with an andor trailer uh
we also got the release date for andor
which we did not know before today
coming out august 31st
two episodes dropping august 31st disney
plus loves doing this they throw two
episodes at us on the same day why not
make a hell out of us yeah why not make
it one huge episode we're not sure
uh but they like doing that and we've
been talking behind the scenes and new
rockstars because we try to plan ahead
okay how are we gonna cover this we're
gonna do an after show wikileaks all
breakdowns all this kind of stuff we're
getting
on august 21st we get game of thrones
house of the dragon yes on august 31st
we get andor on disney plus on september
2nd we get the lord of the rings series
on amazon prime i do there's not enough
of us here within two weeks we're
getting three gigantic i mean this
entire summer is just everything it's
just the boys it's the we gotta get it
all done
we just gotta finish come on i mean we
don't have enough we'll all sleep when
kevin feige is dead and uh there's gonna
be a lot of content to cover we have no
idea how we're gonna do it but we're
going to and we're i mean as fans we're
thrilled how cool is that gonna be that
like three nights of your week you're
like well i know what i'm doing tonight
i will say i i miss game of thrones i
know we all got to to where we got to at
the end but that was such a good like
watch party show right just like gather
people together i hope i can get it with
uh uh the the
the the new one oh god the house of the
dragon yeah yeah i thought you were
going to say you hope you could come to
my watch party
tickets are hard tickets are hard to
come by for the late night watch party
well the baby game of thrones one is
very easy
give me dragons
are pitching for that baby
yeah
i'll be a pa on that show
come over here come on
uh uh
good
the tiniest finger on that little thing
um we got more and or to talk about
we're gonna get all up in your and or
questions yes yes keep throwing those
questions in the chat we're accumulating
them we're gonna be answering a bunch of
those we're also going to talk talk
obi-wan that drops tonight at midnight
oh man what here here we're talking all
this future star wars we've got some
present star wars to deal with well wait
okay okay
you just said
repeat yourself repeat yourself first
two episodes of obi-wan drop tonight at
midnight doesn't also stranger things
drop at do we know if it's yes it is
so we have obi-wan and stranger things
dropping tvs yeah it has two tvs i have
two monitors so i can put them both that
is not a way to enjoy content
and we're gonna try to slam through as
much of this as possible tomorrow on the
break room philip might be back nope
okay philip confirm not here other
special guests here uh jessica and i
tommy will still be down reporting uh
remotely from star wars celebration but
we're gonna talk about those obi-wan
drops and maybe however many minutes of
stranger things we can squeeze in as
well no spoilers for either tomorrow
especially stranger things we probably
won't be getting into deep stranger
things conversation until next week when
everybody's had a chance to watch four
episodes or four episodes those are all
like an hour long or something are they
dropping it all out they're dropping it
all the way yes so we gotta do that's
like
with the obi-wan how many hours of
content do we gotta watch i mean five or
six
you'll be up until 10
[Laughter]
uh
a.m
predictions will come out later in the
show yes we're gonna get to that
predicting what we're gonna get in these
first two episodes of obi-wan someone
said what do you watch first though
that's a hard question do you alternate
i think i would do it i would
yes and then i would go to stranger
things and also 2 a.m you're gonna
start also more spoiled for obi-wan than
you would be first first i i agree i
think i think there will be more people
ready to watch day of day and date on
obi-wan then maybe stranger things but
you did this on purpose can we do a poll
of which what people are more like to
watch like what what what do you need to
watch first yeah let's do a poll on
which one they're watching first so i
actually and i will literally take that
recommendation and take recommendations
speaking of polls i just want to say
phillip and jessica are in great company
47 of people have never even heard of
willow much less seen willa i said have
you heard i've never i've never felt
like more of an elder millennial uh
having that have been a big part of my
childhood i believe i had a couple
figurines um but apparently there needs
to be a will on a willow assance you
know uh no no will on assange
well while i think of a better name for
people watching willow we want to thank
some folks that helped bring this show
to you yes especially our good friends
at athletic greens i'm about
three-quarters uh athletic uh for today
um they're sponsoring all week on the
break room we thank you athletic greens
uh tommy's been drinking athletic greens
in uh this week's episode so far and i'm
drinking them today and you know what
these 75 high quality vitamins minerals
and probiotics they go down nice okay
um drink it
yeah okay i'll say it'll be hard you can
drink it i'll talk about it because i
was researching about it
that it's very specifically engineered
for the founder had like gut health
issues uh and i've had issues medical
issues before where i like got all this
recommendations for expensive treatments
whatever he had the same kind of story
instead was like how about i make my own
liquid that will fix me uh and so it's a
full you know it's a supplement that
actually helped his recovery of his gut
and he made it so that now everybody
else has that optimal i don't need to
get up
they're great and you know what it comes
in a pretty sweet box like this and
actually tommy was saying because he's
been um one of the most passionate
athletic greens consumers on on staff he
just took a couple of these little
packets with them down to anaheim they
travel really well and so there's an
immune boost yes there's an immune boost
minerals and whole foods source
ingredients yes and you know what you
throw it in a little shaker with some
water that's all you need and that's
kind of nice of all the um kind of ways
that you can consume vitamins and
minerals this is a nice travel friendly
one right everybody can forget it set it
and forget it uh and right now hey it's
time to reclaim your health you i'm
talking to you right now you know what
your health has wandered away it's maybe
in the other room it's maybe in an
adjacent county reclaim it okay and arm
your immune system with convenient daily
nutrition one scoop and a cup of water
every day that's it no need for a
million different pills and powders
legitimately i take like almost 40 pills
a day i've seen
phillips pill counter he has like a
significant portion of his kitchen
devoted to pills um you don't need that
you just need uh one of these little
green juices uh
i mean hey whatever it takes uh and to
make it easy athletic greens is gonna
give you a free one-year supply of
immune supporting vitamin d and five
free travel packs with your first
purchase all you have to do is visit
athleticgreens.com
break room the name of this show it's
also a link down here in the video's
description again that's
athleticgreens.com
break room to take ownership over your
health and pick up the ultimate daily
nutritional insurance
thanks athletic greens
also we want a quick shout out as we're
about to get into a little later in the
show some obi-wan talk
we we just dropped on new
rockstarsmerch.com
a very nice new latest obsession shirt
themed after the obi-wan series yeah uh
we you seem very confused well i i
wasn't sure which thing he was he was
going to mention uh we dropped a whole
obi-wan collection including actually
the shirt that i'm wearing
i was gonna comment yeah you got that
shirt i did i played a big role in the
design of this one oh nice um uh also
that is uh not only a wall art oh let me
grab it uh behind that there we go we're
bringing
the higher ground the highest ground
and then uh that looks great and then we
also have the latest obsession and a
couple of other items that are still
coming obviously we always wait till the
series drops too to add a little more um
but yeah i know it's super exciting and
then also because it's a series there'll
be the wikileaks shout out so you'll be
able to with your purchase of the latest
obsession you'll be able to get your
question or shout out scrolling on the
bottom of wikileaks and then eric and
tommy like always say have to tattoo it
they're running out of space those guys
are getting a pretty dense uh full back
that weird tattoo it's the two
to do it yeah when you when you're
giving yourself a tattoo you are
tattooing
oh speaking of horrible jokes oh
it's time for mandatory fun
it's time for mandatory fun but we have
a video from the field i i think i think
we got a video from the field yes no yes
no break room reporting in again
still stealing eric foster's wi-fi uh i
had a great time at my first panel here
at celebration we got a whole weekend
though of stuff i'm gonna have more
stuff to report to you tomorrow
we got a first trailer for mando
season three we got our first look at
the john watts tv show uh called
skeleton crew it's gonna be about four
kids trying to make their way home the
galaxy far far away we got a freaking
willow trailer
it was crazy y'all
i hit my graphic
oh my god even dead in the ground he's
still
playing yeah
he might as well be he's in the desert
uh you guys is mandatory fun hosted by
jessica clemens because tommy is dead in
anaheim and speaking of death i'm a big
horror fan i don't know about you two
huge huge yes yes okay big horror
thriller fan and if you're a big horror
thriller fan you probably heard about
the new winnie the pooh horror thriller
movie that's coming out uh it's called
blood and honey the first look images
are
horrifying it's basically poo and piglet
there it is poo and piglet going on a
rampage you guys oh my god what this is
like a world cup this is like
unauthorized right this is not a.a
milne's estate is right winnie the pooh
is in the public domain oh because it's
so old
wow why did you look at me when you said
that
anyway
i went oh so old my bad
oh
no i'm joking i'm older than phillip so
anyways
that is the most horrifying images it's
pooh and piglet going on a rampage
killing slashing and that got me to
thinking if i were
to
if you guys were to pitch me
a child show that you love dearly made
into a horror
what would it be game of thrones
show
i want to hear their pitches you guys
vote which is the best scariest movie
and whoever the winner is doesn't die is
it just between us no because i want to
throw my name okay and you're also the
judge or we're gonna put it into no
we're gonna give it to the chat okay
because unlike tommy i'm uh i'm here for
democracy are we doing so spooky
so to buy ourselves some time i just
want to throw speaking of uh oh oh
scary lighting nice work for me
speaking of the chat through that poll
up uh what are you watching first a
resounding 86 percent saying kenobi
whoa
stranger things well someone also was
like kenobi it's been so long which is
completely true it's been forever with
this light on my face it's been so long
since we've seen
okay okay
okay okay you guys ready yes you guys
ready
picture if you will an old house
an old house in new york city you're
you're wandering down the street you see
the for sale sign in the house you go up
to it it's empty
there's a lot of technology a little old
prehistoric looking wrecks all on the
ground
you're wandering through it someone
appears out of nowhere you go oh god it
scares you it's the real estate agent
they say the house is on the market if
you're interested you're like i am
interested
who lived here last and they were like
well i have to tell you a child died
here oh heaven a child died here because
their parents performed an experiment
where he went into their tunnel when he
wasn't supposed to and all you hear is
danny phantom phantom phantom
danny phantom phantom phantom phantom
danny phantom that sounds familiar right
that sounds familiar to us the ghost boy
and they're like
we don't say his name around these parts
fast forward she's moving in you're
moving in everybody's moving into this
house but every night someone disappears
and all that's left behind is a
footprint in the shape of a d with blood
on the floor
then it's danny phantom
he's killing everybody in that house
he's being avenged by his parents that
killed him that one day
his parents killed him his parents
killed him
is that the premise of the show i've
never seen it oh my god oh yeah i've
never seen danny phantom either i don't
even know well technically his parents
didn't kill him they made a machine i'll
sing you the song yo danny phantom he
was just 14 when his parents built a
very strange machine it was designed to
see a world unseen he's going to catch
them all because he's danny phantom he
went into that machine and he got turned
into a ghost
sheriff did kill him jessica
you can finish this pitch with some
profanity if you like
yo danny phantom that [ __ ] spirit
if he's here today he's going to come
out and kill philip i mean not philip
he's going to kill all of us danny
phantom said [ __ ] that [ __ ] and [ __ ] my
parents i'm gonna kill all these
[ __ ] in this house today wow
this certainly was not what i agree that
that pitch shifted like that that pitch
became very samuel l jackson at the end
of these [ __ ] spirits in their
[ __ ] house uh thank you to bubashet
uh for throwing out a nice super chat
there christina hubiker uh sean bell a
bunch of folks thank you all for we hit
our 100 threshold thus unlocking the
swear jar for jessica thank you so mine
was a [ __ ] sure i can go um i'll go
next uh
san francisco
early 90s the fog rolls in
off the bay
we come up on a
beautiful
uh
brick town home we go inside oh it's a
it's a fun family it's oh it's it's a
mixed family you know family is not
necessarily just blood it's it's who you
make it and this is a group like that
you know everybody is is getting along
they love each other they're okay
expressing that love openly
except for the youngest in the family
she's a beautiful
cute precocious little toe-headed girl
with evil inside of her
i know okay
and when nobody's looking when
when danny
or joey
or any of the other tanner family aren't
looking
evil michelle comes out
and only after after the end of the film
right and the big climax after she's
killed the milkman the paperboy even tv
okay is it revealed that oh
the michelle they thought they were
dealing with
was a twin
i love this i'm here for this evil full
house let's make this happen okay that's
a good idea yeah that's a great idea
[Applause]
yes very ready i love these these are
fun
meet
george judson
his boy elroy
daughter judy
jane
his wife
oh god
grieving actually because his boy elroy
is with us no more
he suffered a uh terrible allergy and
even in the future the year 2150
they weren't able to save him so this
family's morning
and
his wife jane she just really can't even
bring herself to get out of space bed so
she uh it's just letting herself go
she's letting the house go george
doesn't know what to do so george brings
home a robot made
named rosie
housekeeper she's going to go ahead and
help take care of the house while he
works
take care of his daughter beauty take
care of jane
and then
john comes in and scares me
[Applause]
but
uh stuff starts happening to jane she
starts feeling weird uh she feels like
something is wrong and something's
working against her and so she wants to
go visit her mother
in her flying car oh and on her way
there the flying car's engine gives out
somebody has perhaps sabotaged it
the flying car plummets back to earth
somehow she barely survives oh my god no
one believes her that someone's after
her then she starts seeing images of her
dead son elroy blaming her oh my god
and following her throughout the house
torturing her so much she jumps off the
sky deck of their five mile high
killing herself i love this now of
course
daughter judy is absolutely just
aside beside herself with with with
grief not cleaning her room though not
letting rosie in to clean the room
that's because she's also on space pills
oh my god
and so
then rosie
just reminds her that she really does
need to clean
suddenly uh judy's room
which again is in the space bubble yes
gets uh depressurized using the porthole
that gets the oxygen out of the room but
judy's still in there but it's a small
port oh but wow his body is sucking okay
this is the full plot sucked out
we can skip ahead a little bit uh as
uh uh george uh finds that it is rosie
who is killing his family members rosie
is in love with george he chops rosie's
head off it goes flying down rosie has
actually bloomed playing holograms of
his boy elroy driving his wife crazy all
these things oh my god rosie just wants
to be with him
but
uh they're never gonna be together uh
but wait hold on oh my god there's
holograms of the of this family this
happy family these are rosie's last
images except they're not rosie's last
images they're actually a space
psychiatrist reviewer dear lord elroy's
memories because elroy is in an
institution elroy killed his mother and
wow
he tells himself that it was the robot
but it wasn't it was all along george
has lost his entire family god even his
boy elroy oh my god
somebody should have been typing this up
because this is a pretty decent legit
pitch jetson's hand that rocks the
cradle will sell also i know for a fact
phillip was literally doing all that off
the dome he did not pre-plan any of this
i know a lot of the chat won't believe
that that is philip has the ability to
improvise a pitch like that which is
both impressive and chilling frankly
look i
lived a very similar story
very easy to access
someone in the chat said
uh evil full house it's called empty
house oh
like that the netflix show uh where like
all the people had died in that house
cover and they still they stay there
also the ryan murphy showdown
a house on the haunted hills or whatever
that's great that's great great great
pitches i want to hear in the chat
throw it in the chat i want to pull
jessica phillips hat on a hat or
zacks which was your favorite score
scary score of the story and you said
one of us doesn't die that's right yeah
the winner doesn't die so are you here
hell yeah wow eternal life
man i should have been participating
even even more in these
really good
before we get to kenobi predictions i
want to
go to the chat a little bit we've had
some good andor uh things thrown into
the chat and some other good things i
just want to throw out um
uh
here for the cookies saying zach can you
please partner with netflix so we can
get some discounted subscriptions to
watch stranger things
absolutely here for the cookies netflix
hit me up
uh we'd love to do a sponsorship with
netflix um and uh also a happy birthday
to louis smith who wants us to cover the
witcher maybe maybe when the next season
drops and then um dodson if we could
throw some of those and or questions up
there as well we'll start guns
i saw one earlier and it really excites
me i i don't remember who it was
hopefully dawson's gonna be able to pull
it up but somebody asked what is going
to be the most surprising cameo in andor
and so remember andor is taking place in
the events leading up to rogue one yes
so we know that that's where they're
headed uh and the rebellion is is going
but also this is post uh revenge of the
sith so this is very much the empire
kind of at the height of its power
and there's a really cool uh moment in
the trailer we see a quick flash of the
senate
and
we've never actually seen in in episode
four we just hear the the sentence been
dissolved we saw them
you know jar jar do some some masterful
work
but here i think we're gonna get the
actual senate in like the the height of
of kind of like the nazi rule kind of
thing
i wonder if we're gonna get steve
palpatine
oh
yeah i mean that guy will show up he he
loves playing that role
yeah um that's a great one um especially
like that might be a little unexpected
it would surprise people it's not also
the giant you know trump card of a luke
or a leia or something like that oh this
is also sorry this is going back to the
other question uh and also i i i'm sorry
i don't know this did we not do the
breakdown of the witcher
we we covered the very first season we
haven't um
been covering that but you know what if
enough people demand it a lot of it is
just kind of like what our audience is
into at that moment and witcher's always
kind of been just beneath the surface
for us for our bandwidth you know which
are i really like the show
few too many little songs i think for
for me to
see
too many songs yeah i also i've never
read the books i just played a little
bit of the game so i don't know enough
about the winter yes but maybe we'll
we'll see what happens with that new
season thank you for the the super chat
um and then real quick uh in gravoy i'm
not sure how to pronounce your name it's
been a tough week in texas thank you
guys for a good laugh absolutely much
love to all our our viewers out there in
texas we hope you're you're doing all
right uh who do you think the most
surprising character appearance will be
in android that's kind of a similar
question there that's the one i think do
we have any other guesses for who else
so now this is uh so i've seen some
speculation online right the animated
series version of maul
is out there at around this time right
like this has already been cut in half
but has come back in some in some kind
of way right he's like underground in
the tunnels being rebuilt
potentially we don't know how the
live-action
world is going to treat
kind of uh
solo but he's already
he's like that which is a very similar
time yes yeah so he is around running
the uh crimson dawn yes
uh yeah that's pretty pretty decent
guess manipulating things behind the
scenes we'd see do we think we'd see
this we'd see maul and andor
that's a does that yes yeah we're
staying in andor yeah that'd be nice um
because like we see we see a lot of
different empire type figures right the
administrator the generals all these
kind of people yes i have an observation
about these kind of people please
watching this because again it's like at
the height of the empire so we're really
seeing it like really going i was like
oh when it's really going i'm sure now
they'll finally be uh plenty
non-humanoid-looking
people they're no
you never notice that that like there
are so many species
out there oh star wars the empire is
always just like british dudes that's a
great point i've never really thought
about that the resistance the rebels
very diverse all kinds we got akbar
akbar is in a leadership position right
like lots of uh
isn't a human but other than that it's
true you're basically just dealing with
like and mostly white people just white
people yeah it's like so weirdly
specific now now to be fair we don't
know what everybody looks like under
those stormtrooper hoods
well we know what they did at one point
yeah then we know that they have but
they also they regulate what height
they're supposed to be they're probably
putting them in there and you can't have
like a giant fish head and fit under
that helmet right i mean we've been
fighting for rights for a long time
please we need fish head accessible
storm trooper helmets allow fish heads
in the in the military they're trying to
volunteer their fish please they want to
serve okay um uh great we'll come back
and get some more android questions as
just straight up uh what is andor about
and i don't know how much we know well
this is just following up to
this is following up to rogue one this
is no this
here's what's crazy they already are
shooting season two of this we're
getting two
12 episode seasons of andor the second
season will end presumably with rogue
one yeah uh and so we'd see mon mothma
probably also that'd be good good guess
uh of someone that would be important uh
building up i think that this is gonna
be just based on the vibes because we
didn't hear much i was i was getting not
not to call back the joke from earlier
but i was getting game of thrones vibes
yeah and i was getting a little bit of
that uh movie slash based on true story
valkyrie yeah tom cruise movie yeah
where it's a plot to assassinate hitler
yes uh that fails that fame
a little bit in glorious bastards too is
a little bit of fictionalized version of
that yeah i wonder if it's like okay we
have the senate they're in power and we
know that uh eventually it's gonna be
this thing about destroying the death
star and that's gonna be the way to take
him down but how did they try to take
them down using uh we all know that the
resistance rebellion is based on this
kind of guerrilla warfare slash kind of
like terrorist
uh
tactics are they probably are going to
try to like either infiltrate the
government or maybe like try to like
blow up the senate yeah something and
and we know like again this is kind of
big news for us
this is the first time like any of these
disney plus series out of the gate
basically
have been ordered to two seasons yeah
nothing else has right this is like
they're going to start filming the
second season in november basically
a quick but not only kind of green lit
after the first season was coming out
this is like the first season hasn't
even started airing they're already
being like yeah the second season starts
shooting in november and we'll probably
get maybe end of 2023 probably likely
beginning at 2024 we get the second
season of this so it's cool like people
are very excited about obi-wan there's a
lot of people very excited about ahsoka
mandalorian season three but it seems
like actually lucasfilm is pouring kind
of the most focus into this andor two
season series right like it's gonna be a
really important part we're gonna get 24
weeks of this over the next kind of two
three years whitaker's heavy breathing
that's my uh that's my white noise
machine at home it's just forest
whitaker heavy breathing yeah um we're
very excited for it and we'll have a lot
more and or talk in the coming weeks as
we get more details yeah and we'll have
a
full trailer breakdown sometime soon
eric will do his best in the next few
days we've got two obi-wan episodes to
break down we'll have stranger things
it's gonna be a madhouse on the channel
over the next three four days but uh
look look for that coming out on the
channel soon but yeah we've gotta back
up we're talking again all these future
star wars series we got one coming out
tonight two episodes of kenobi dropping
so we're gonna do as this will be our
last break room before those first two
episodes just some quick predictions
from us things we'd like to see things
too
yes well yeah let's stick to just these
first two episodes uh maybe after they
come out we can try to predict for the
whole rest of the series um now my
favorite
question that we were kind of debating
back and forth we know we get a scene
between owen uncle owen and obi-wan
right there's some kind of confrontation
there where he's like oh like your old
student you're going to take care of him
like you did anakin um that great quote
from the trailer i i just butchered it
and it came off like that for me thank
you thank you uh so do we think somebody
was predicting are we gonna see like a
physical fight between obi-wan and ellen
not in the first two episodes oh i would
love it though i think at the end of the
second episode is when we're going to
get like a taste of vader just to see a
little piece and it's because it's like
oh like oh my god but like wouldn't it
be great to get like a taste of obi-wan
too yeah right like imagine think about
um clark kent when he's kind of being
like like messed with uh and he's trying
to like not
do anything super manny if owen is kind
of like hitting obi-wan i'm kind of like
beating him up and everyone's trying to
like kind of take it yeah actually just
like
yeah and just kind of like
just a quick force
yeah yeah yeah yeah
remind us like how powerful he is i like
that cause like obi-wan is this kind of
like monk-like figure he's trying to be
zen and chill and cool but this dude is
coming for him right he's he's he's
flicking him on his like most raw nerve
right like his biggest failure in life
probably uh to see like oh
does obi-wan ever lose it does he
lose it in this oh we're gonna see him
lose it he's gonna break down i think
there's too much that he's been like
away from and then it's all gonna
especially when he sees vader and
realizes anakin that's gonna hit well oh
go ahead well there's also kathleen
kennedy had this quote about how they
considered strongly uh having had
obi-wan have a love interest at times
and then you know the whole thing about
whether or not he was going to be ray's
father grandfather or something like
that
and then the reason they decided against
it they're like no we want him to
essentially be this monk that it's just
too important to him to ever uh
entertain love and that sounds
frustrating as hell
definitely like to be that guy just like
i mess up real bad i'm gonna go hide in
the desert and i'm never going to know
the touch of another person yes
i'm about to blow up already talking
about it
i feel like kenobi would be the one to
be like
to straight up just be like i know what
can get me to the dark side and i'm not
going to even entertain and we know
these inquisitors right those people are
going to piss them off they're going to
push some buttons right because it's
also like dramatically from a writer's
perspective it's not fun to see a
character that never gets upset of
course right like every character needs
some kind of arc they need to like be at
their low point and they screw things up
say it again
say it again say it to my face see what
happens
yes uh english imperialist seen it to my
face um well speaking jessica just
invoked vader do we see
vader in the first two episodes yes
vader or anakin oh
i guess he would have already had it
descended i think we're gonna see the
vader first before we see the anakin
okay so we see
hayden christensen no face no burnt up
face just just black helmet yeah okay we
see that that's the end of episode two
yeah is the shot of vader's helmet
either in silhouette or direct on and
it's at the same moment that obi-wan is
learning anakin is alive
i think that's it i think philip just
nailed it there there's often we've kind
of noticed this in the past disney plus
loves to like drop a couple episodes at
the beginning and often it's because
something big happens at the end of that
last episode they drop right like
they're like oh though this is
technically two episodes but this is
what's gonna hook you for the whole
thing here's something actually that
might
i don't i don't have any stakes because
i'm not going to be on the show tomorrow
so i can make any predictions i i want
uh but you guys uh for your predictions
um something that i'll even add for you
guys to go further normally the press
can receive these episodes early just a
couple episodes to build up hype uh
disney refused to send out any episodes
early for obi-wan which would imply that
immediately in the first two episodes
are such big spoilers they don't want
anybody to know yes i i like that
because like people are already watching
miss marvel
uh episodes and that doesn't come out
for another couple weeks right like yeah
a lot of these things get reviewed by
the press early and this one didn't i
think that's a great point they know
that like something big happens and that
it would get out
taking big swings
you take your big swing okay what
happens i think i'm going to go we both
see vader and we see burnt up face
yes
and they're not the same person
we're making our big swings on anakin
and vader or any period
what do you think is the reason that
disney might not have wanted this to get
out there's some big spoilery thing that
happens i think it has to be someone
bigger than
vader which is bigger than vader when i
say this i say this because it's like we
already saw the vader we already saw
vader it's like it's like multiverse and
madness we already saw um
professor x but we didn't see you mr
reed richards yeah
[Laughter]
so i'm trying to think of like who
i'm trying to think that will take me
thinking for a minute okay because it's
well i mean
i think we've gotten confirmation
what
zombie zombies force goes qui-gon
especially because he said he was not
gonna literally liam neeson's one of the
only star wars actors that's never
done interviews never been mentioned i
think is like very much like no i don't
want to come back yoda said that uh
qui-gon had like mastered that ability
to be a horse ghost
that would be good i mean the mace windu
of it all
he's often mentioned i don't think it's
amazing i mean why he could come back
just as easily i would love it to be
mace win oh well also what i wanted to
do yeah also as a force ghost or there's
all these you know very conspiracy
theory though i think liam neeson's a
big one because he's been so audible or
just loud about that like i'm not doing
a series i refuse to do a series only
movies and so to come back to this is
just like um
i like that that's a bold bet okay i
like that also only some jedi are like
good enough to do force ghosts like if
mace windu can't he's just like like
he's floating out there and he's like
great
come on can you see me
i see a lot of comments for jar jar
binks um
i mean that would that might break the
internet did they bring back we'll just
face andre whatever the oh yeah jar jar
who said that it ruined his entire life
that's legitimately true well hey it's a
change for redemption
is happening to the uh yes
yeah hayden christensen couple folks
have some ideas here quentin b sand will
we see a young lando
in andor oh now it would have to be
donald glover right oh yeah though
kathleen kennedy's saying she kind of
regrets having done any recasting
for the younger version oh instead of
just getting uh she wishes
billy dean
yeah you can't do that with him
d h billy dee williams
okay much healthy
healthy vibes to billy d williams um we
also got uh jose rodriguez saying grand
admiral thrawn
yeah i mean that doesn't make sense it
would it would line up with what i'm
saying where it's like otherwise it's
just a lot of evil humans
yeah um and then this this kind of uh
dovetails with another thing we were
saying like how much flashback footage
will we see right how much time will we
spend in between uh the prequel trilogy
in the beginning of obi-wan kind of like
in book of effect there was so much kind
of like jumping back and forth in time
flashbacks to different parts of the
boba life uh
uh rush attack ml saying do you think
the clone trooper shot in the trailer
was a flashback that's gonna uh watch uh
eric's breakdown yeah
yeah yeah i'm i'm not sure i do not
remember that exact shot from the
trailer though i'm excited for any clone
trooper to get their comeuppance i think
uh uh just thinking back for the thrawn
thing for a second it would make sense
if they're trying to do kind of what
they do with mandalorian boba fett of
other stories that are setting up ahsoka
yes yeah
yeah
yeah that's great well also i mean we
know we're going to see a young luke
right we saw that in the trailer
apparently that's going to be a big
thrust of the season
young leia
young leia would be not okay
with her passing uh oh well but it's oh
you don't think even
because um carrie fisher i mean it's not
gonna be a deal you don't think they
would recast like a nine-year-old
actress i mean like the same age as
young luke you know what i mean uh
whatever
a child age
oh uh yeah god could they if the h carry
to nine-year-old status too much yeah
okay that um they would have to show
well they are showing the senate she's
on alderaan yeah but it depends on
whether or not we see bail or ghana i
would say right right jimmy smits i mean
i love seeing that
come on the show jimmy smits coward
god godly god
it makes us we demand it now we're
getting to all nothing but love to jimmy
smith
speaking
now that we're insulting beloved actors
it's about that time um uh thank you to
everybody uh for throwing in we're gonna
be i mean tomorrow
oh what we're gonna say no sorry i was
gonna say that the horror stories philip
won oh
running away 40 pills a day running away
and we do have uh joe now uh rodriguez
saying bob the builder uh where the
vehicles help him kill and hide the
bodies and the scarecrow comes back to
haunt him rodriguez let's uh let's link
up so we can write this all right that's
a nice pitch too maybe where all the
cars are killing oh terminal overdrive
or something like that
yes
maximum overdrive thank you thank you uh
yeah that's a stephen king his first
directorial effort
he did that and christine yes just hates
cars homeboy loves murderous cards i
think maximum overdrive uh don't quote
me if i'm wrong maximum drive i know for
sure cujo was the one that stephen king
wrote in like a coke fueled hate yes a
lot of his a lot of his 70s 80s output i
wrote cujo when i was 10 years old and
you got me in a cookie
you've never partied harder than after
reading kujo
um speaking of partying hard we think
everybody uh watching today as we
partied here back physically in the
break room it's been so nice to be
physically back together we paid our
internet bill i'm very good to be back
in the audience it's a long story that
we'll go into someday on a future break
room who needs internet that's right um
apparently you do to live stream uh show
a lot of youtube company
yes
uh we'll be back tomorrow having watched
those first two episodes episodes of
obi-wan we'll have a lot of drinking yes
uh tommy and philip or tommy and eric
you'll be drinking uh yeah we'll be
drinking some of that nice uh uh
athletic greens and i was gonna say some
of that i almost said back to tank water
and that's it that's not gonna be tasty
rosario dawson's back to tank wow
um uh we'll be back tomorrow and and all
next week we'll be talking obi-wan we'll
still be kind of recuperating from all
this great star wars news and starting
to get into some of this miss marvel uh
content that'll be uh hitting us the
boys comes next week we'll be talking
about that
uh it's an exciting time to be alive i'm
gonna be so tired tomorrow
we're all gonna be so tired tomorrow
watching this show and i'm gonna be
tipsy as well so let's just have fun
tomorrow i always exhaust you i find uh
uh guys thank you so much for having me
it's always nice to to drop into the
break room thank you for being here
thank you guys so much for keeping up
with this show i hope you're getting
like value out of it i'm keeping up with
the nerve news by watching this show i
hope that our fans are too and yeah
that's the best part oh stop i have no
nails that was my favorite part about
this show is like i get all my nerves
from it so when anyone's talking about
it i'm like well zach mentioned
yesterday
did you know it would have been cass
yeah um big big question you guys don't
answer tomorrow uh chrissy asks if you
touched akbar would you feel smooth
slimy warm or oddly cool tomorrow
brandon would love that question yeah
brandon knows the answer i'm pretty sure
he might have touched jack barr uh
already um let's all touch ackbar
tonight guys strive for greatness
it's a trap
[Music]
you